bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france d'abord
peut-être votre réaction à l'agression
entre guillemets un vécu par jean luc
mélenchon qui a été en farine et cet
après midi vous avez pu voir peut-être
les images comment vous réagissez et
briguer celle oui bonjour merci pour
l'invitation
il ya là dedans ça pas avoir sa place
dans le débat politique ça nuit au débat
d'idées
c'est dommage a été plus intéressant
pour un débattre sur le fond en train de
le faire actuellement que justement
savoir qu'est ce qu'on pouvait reprocher
à jean luc mélenchon par rapport à ses
déclarations et en débattre de manière
démocratique
la violence et ce geste n'apporte
absolument rien au débat mme c'est
absolument à proscrire
michel fize est ce que vous voyez là
dans cette action de 2,7 en farine heure
justement une forme d'extrémisme pas moi
j'ai fait quand même la différence entre
la gifle reçue par le président de la
république il ya quelques jours et c'est
en farine âge c'est pas nouveau la
farine âge il y a dans le passé des
hommes politiques qui sont faites en
farine et je pense même à un homme
politique lionel jospin à qui on avait
déversé du ketchup pour l'inviter à
rosir rougir son discours voyez donc je
pense encore une fois bon pour
regrettable que soit c'est en sept ans
farine âge je pense que c'est pas quand
même du même niveau de d'inquiétude que
l'on peut avoir par rapport à une gifle
adressée quand même au premier
personnage de l'état
alors justement on va écouter langue
farine heures rt l'a d'ailleurs
retrouver aussi et
il avait crié collabos juste avant son
action il se définit comme un homme de
gauche non on les écoute il avait réagi
juste après par un ras-le-bol vis-à-vis
de ces gens en fait tout tout politiques
confondues 1 de marine le pen à jean luc
mélenchon
personne n'écoute vraiment le peuple ils
ne défendent qu'une caste bourgeoise et
joue sur des petits des beauty des
petits thème complètement secondaire
mais qui ne vont jamais aidé le les gens
il faudrait se rassembler et à arrêter
de parler notamment d'immigration
l'immigration c'est terrible parce que
la gauche n'en parle jamais la droite ne
parle que de ça oui ce que je veux dire
il ya un vrai problème
et au final c'est la seule démarcation
aujourd'hui entre la gauche et la droite
il faut être de bon sens il ya des
choses qu'on peut faire pour que tout le
monde aille mieux
nous on ne les fait pas voilà donc
c'était aujourd'hui marche des libertés
contre les idées dit d'extrême droite
lorsque vous entendez cet enfer et leur
dire que finalement gauche droite c'est
quasiment la même chose comment vous
réagissez à vrai que c'est alors c'est
c'est intéressant sur ce point de vue et
notamment son propos il n'y a pas de
différence sur les politiques impliqués
de droite et de gauche et finalement une
forme de malaise et d'absence du
politique et de propositions une absence
de clarté dans les propositions et le
clivage gauche droite l'élection de
manuel macro et un peu symptomatiques de
deux phénomènes où finalement on a eu l
droite de la gauche et l gauche de la
droite qui sont retrouvés sur un projet
entre social-démocratie et et libéraux
aux chrétiens-démocrates et donc ça
participe à cette idée que finalement
les politiques de droite ou de gauche se
démène et dans le même temps on a un
phénomène de polarisation ou à droite
comme à gauche on a des idées et des
propositions pour répondre à cette offre
qui est central qui sont de plus en plus
extrêmes et sa salle
son propos est il de ce traitement se
fait de m finalement on aurait un bloc
central à la fois de droite et de gauche
qui serait unique et finalement le
peuple abandonné qui n'aurait comme
seule alternative que des extrêmes
extrême rareté extrême gauche est elle
dans son cas où il dit que même
mélenchon et le pen ferait partie de
cette caste politique du centre
et c'est quelque chose qui peut être
ressenti par beaucoup de citoyens et en
partie expliquent les fort taux
d'abstention et notamment le fait que le
mouvement des gilet jaune a été au début
dit d'extrême droite finalement plutôt
senti comme d'extrême gauche une fois
qu'il y avait et à bloc et 7
cette difficulté est finalement à placer
sur le spectre politique
une frange de la population qui se dit
comme mon affilée et qui a du mal à se
reconnaître dans leur politique actuelle
vous êtes d'accord michel fize on
rappelle par exemple que l'homme tu es à
gifler à emmanuel macron se présenter
comme un anarchiste
je crois que pour enchaîner sur le
propos qui vient d'être retenu que je
partage il faut il faut bien avoir
conscience que nous sommes à une phase
que nous sommes face pardon à une crise
générale des légitimités et en
particulier de la légitimité politique
qui se traduit par un rejet de la seule
représentation comme mode d'expression
démocratique qui se traduit par le rejet
des leaderships politiques qui se
traduit par le roger des élections
eux-mêmes qui se traduit par le rejet
des politiques donc dans l'esprit de
beaucoup de français
les politiques sont devenus dans le cas
de cette société que j'appelle société
de l'individualisme triomphant sont
devenus des citoyens comme les autres
donc insulte à bhl agréé sable vilipende
abl que l'on peut en farine et voilà ya
une vingtaine d'années on n'aurait pas
par exemple agressé un maire dans une
dans une commune un tout au plus lui
auront lui aurait-on fait quelques
remarques sur tel ou tel point de sa
gestion mais depuis une vingtaine
d'années on a une montée 1 des
agressions y compris contre ce qui
politiquement était lé plus les plus
protégés jusqu'à jusqu'à présent voilà
donc je pense que on est face à un
problème aussi d'une société qui est en
perte de repères voilà et qui est face à
une grande souffrance comme l'a dit
effectivement dans le reportage
ce garçon bon les gens sont mécontents
mais mécontent c'est un terme
faible les gens sont dans une grande
souffrance telle que ont pu le montrer
les gilet jaune il ya deux ans et qui
leur montreront probablement encore dans
quelques mois
donc la situation s'est aggravée donc il
ya un problème je dirais qui
consisterait en termes de solutions à
rebâtir une démocratie politiquement
partageuse là avec une alliance de la
démocratie représentative classiques et
des morceaux de démocratie directe
d'autre part et puis il faut aussi
inventer une démocratie économique et on
parle beaucoup des extrêmes mais on
n'oublie pas ce qu'il faut faire le lien
entre le social et politique
c'est que on est dans une société
d'extrême inégalités c'est quand même
assez paradoxal qu'au cours de la
dernière année
les riches sont devenus plus riches
qu'auparavant il ya d'ailleurs même plus
de riches qu'il y a un an et les pauvres
sont encore plus pauvres qui qu'il y un
an
voilà ça c'est pas conforme encore une
fois à la loi démocratique qui veut le
partage et qui veut ne pas laisser au
bord du chemin
un nombre grandissant de personnes donc
les gens est-ce que vous pensez que lors
de cette marche de liberté pour rebondir
un peu sur l'analyse de michel fize vous
pensez que ce n'est pas le rassemblement
national elle est née les idées
politiques d'extrême droite qui était
visé cet après midi il ya un enjeu qui
est très politique à travers cette
manifestation c'est de créer de l'unité
est un un dénominateur commun à toute la
gauche
ce qu'on observe c'est finalement
actuellement la gauche et en europe une
étude de l'innovation pour la fondation
politique qui l'a montré l'europe est à
droite
les citoyens sont globalement plutôt
attachés aux valeurs de droite et à une
transition à montblanc une droitisation
de la société assez importante
et finalement il ya peu à peu près 30%
de l'électorat à des citoyens qui se
disent de gauche et en même temps dans
ses 30 % de citoyens qui se disent de
gauche on a des partis et des gosses qui
sont en cas de mutation pierre conte à
l'ancienne gauche qui était plutôt
république elle plutôt universaliste
plutôt portée vers l'idée de progrès
plutôt structure
et à travers la question se retient et
dans le même temps on a une nouvelle
gauche qui émergent de plus en plus
plutôt porté sur l'écologie et notamment
à des passants qui sont plutôt des
valeurs conservatrices et donc plutôt en
contradiction avec l'idée progrès qui se
structurent davantage autour de la
question de la lutte des races octobre
la lutte est déclassé qui met les
identités au premier plan et dans le
même temps même sur la question de
l'universel et la laïcité qui pour une
certaine gauche et un certain moment
temps avec une forme de complaisance
avec l'islamisme pour de façon
électorale non d'ailleurs
et en fait on a sept construit entre les
deux gauches et finalement le point
qu'il permet peut-être de les réunir que
c'est de lutter contre l'extrême droite
ont tout cassé ce valeurs maison pour
agir halal c'est justement michel fize
mais on va faire réagir michel fize là
dessus mais on va écouter d'abord jean
luc mélenchon c'était juste avant son
enfant images il faut vraiment que dans
le pays à un sursaut qui répondent à la
situation qu'ils ont sommes en train de
vivre un déploiement violent
de l'extrême droite dimona
de mort qui frappe le président qui
tient le haut du pavé dans une groupe
les ans intellectuels de toutes sortes
de commentateurs est là pour la première
fois qu'on bien longtemps il ya une
centaine d'organisations syndicales
associatives et politiques qui sont
ensemble et c'est ça qui me paraît être
le poids lourd le plus intéressant de la
journée
bon avec l'espoir que ce soit le
commencement de quelque chose
qu'ils nous voient nous redéployer
porter à nouveau avec l'audace et fierté
nos idées nos idéaux la fin je mérite
pas d'être perpétuellement submergé par
le discours d'extrême droite michel 6
c'est l'extrême droite qui est visé dans
les propos en tout cas de jean-luc
mélenchon
il ne donne pas le sentiment que ce
rassemblement il parle évidemment d'une
centaine d'organisations y avait pas que
des partis politiques présents lors de
cette marche de liberté
il y avait aussi des syndicats mais
voilà on ne donne pas le sentiment que
c'était un prétexte justement à l'unité
de la gauche
mais ce qui est assez paradoxal dans
cette affaire c'est que le rassemblement
national pour leur apparaît comme la
seule alternative possible
bon il y a effectivement un programme
qui n'est pas un programme très chargé
mais il ya quand même quelques idées
évidemment qu'ils sont qui sont mises en
avant le problème aujourd'hui que
rencontre la classe politique c'est
qu'elle ne pense plus il n'y a plus de
pensée politique
la politique est devenue une affaire de
communication une affaire de pseudo
débat une affaire d'image
voilà tel ou tel se présente pour
défendre on ne sait pas trop lequel quel
projet va ici je pense que autant
évidemment on ne doit pas être agrippés
à des projets à des programmes est
enfermé effectivement dans dans ce type
de document il faut quand même eu une
orientation donc de ce point de vue là
jean luc mélenchon à un programme
il a effectivement un corps de deux
doctrines voilà il a une avancée sociale
politique voilà c'est une vraie
philosophie qui le qu'il dégage
or le problème de l' autre gauche celle
qui n'est pas radical au sens de la
france insoumise et bien elle ne porte
pas de projets elle ne porte pas de
projets on a même l'impression que les
think tanks bon qui ont beaucoup peut
aider à la réflexion
ces dernières des sont à côté de la
sphère politique qu'elle n'aide pas et
qu'elle n'aide pas
qu'on ne fait pas appel à eux un qu'elle
n'aide pas à forger une riposte
un parce que demander à n'importe quel
responsable politique
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait par rapport à
une situation qui est gravissime
sur le plan politique sur le plan
économique sur le plan social sur le
plan moral
pour conclure rapidement d'ailleurs
aller la gauche inquiets qui a décidé en
ordre dispersé les leaders n'ont pas
défilé ensemble que ce soit la france
insoumise le parti communiste europe
ecologie les verts ou le parti
socialiste rapidement un vrai glissait
oui pour réagir il ya un double enjeu
le premier enjeu c'est de répondre à ce
vote si les citoyens votent pour le
parti de marine le pen pour le
rassemblement national c'est qu'ils ont
des raisons c'est que ceux de partis au
répond à certaines de ses attentes ou en
tout cas quand on regarde les études il
ya un roger de toutes les autres les
autres partis politiques qui fait que
lille se tourner vers cette offre
politique donc il ya un premier enjeu
c'est de répondre à ces citoyens qui
expriment un malaise des tanguy et des
préoccupations pour y répondre et
ensuite c'est la question des îles et où
j'ai porté une vision ya pas eu de
défilé
seniors d celle en ordre dispersé un de
la part de la gauche c'était ma question
ça relève d'un calcul politique
al'approche de d'échéances électorales
importantes
il ya un conflit il ya un conflit entre
entre ces deux gauches notamment on peut
entre le ps et europe ecologie les verts
la question c'est de savoir si c'est
l'ancien parti ou le nouveau qui va
réussir à précocité la base électorale
de l'autre donc pour l'instant ils sont
ceux dans ce conflit dans ce bras de fer
pour savoir qui va réussir à prendre
l'avantagé sur l'autre et bénéficier de
l'effet vote utile pour finalement faire
baisser l'autre partie donc pour
l'instant il n'a aucun intérêt à
s'afficher ensemble et continuer plutôt
le bras de fer
merci à vous et mary glisser chaque
radar général adjoint du team tente
millénaire merci à vous michel fize
sociologue auteur en rappel de votre
ouvrage de la bima l'espoir les années
folles du mondialisme de 1945 à 2020 aux
éditions mimesis